what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today the movie smile first time
watching this joined by the co-host ah
the co-host oh my the John Humphrey how
are you doing John I am so I'm spooky
yes you're spooky hi hi myself I'm
spooky I'm excited to be here though how
are you sir doing good ladies and
gentlemen what I'm asking of you guys
right now is to smile your way to that
like button that would make us smile
indeed also uh if you would be so kind
as to check out our patreon page become
a super sexy reject full interaction
watch alongs where you single with your
own copy of smile available over there
along with a bunch of other shows that
we cover exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
also you don't want to thank everyone
who bought themselves a vekna I got some
cat hair on it right now because I'm
just holding a cab for defect
uh real rejects exclusive from our shop
uh seriously that support is insane
saying and it's one of my favorites that
we have so thank you now let's get to
smiling
[Music]
wow this person did not have their life
together
it's a full prescription though
she left her children behind
foreign
was that her as a child core memories
Dr cutter
let's keep repeating your affirmations
I bet what he's saying is going to come
true
I think you're having another manic
episode don't
don't you tell me what you're
experiencing
feels real but it can't hurt you
I want to believe you
on a nice pink Hospital
[Music]
[Music]
oh great shot yeah
did you send a patient named uh Sarah
Marquette is cow pen I was like I
recognize the voice pretty fast Rose she
has no insurance okay but she needs
treatment the board is down my throat
about paying out of pocket for another
bed in The Residency program maybe the
board should try giving a [ __ ] about the
point of our job here once
let's get this guy in the saw six trap
listen over report for a different
incident she was involved in last week
what was that one about
it's the only witness I'm finding a lot
of things to smile about
[Laughter]
it is the best medicine I'm seeing
something
no one else can see it for me what
it looks like people
but it's not a person
oh
I'm not sure I understand it looks like
people it looks like different people
sometimes it pretends to be someone that
I know sometimes it's a random stranger
sometimes
looks like my grandfather it's like a
it follows situations
smiling at me
the worst smile
of [ __ ] to happen around me it's taking
over my whole life and my mind and
damn lady I believe you yeah
die and no one will listen to me okay
Laura it's okay
Laura
can you look at me please
I should get those marks on her face
oh you feel it you feel it don't you
lady
holy crap I have a patient emergency
eval too I need staff here now he's like
strong solid colors are really
weird
is this a fantasy
awesome
[Music]
uh yep yeah she's gonna do something
messed up isn't she yep yeah here it is
oh oh
you should do the whole face just gonna
oh Wowie
drew that smile a little crooked there
yikes
I actually gonna carve a whole face off
yeah
and then stick it on your face
back
to me oh that's creepy yeah you know you
guys YouTube's very strict lately so if
you're watching this on YouTube there's
some things you're just gonna have to
make sure you've seen the movie yourself
on the blank you know what's happening
welcome to the blurry reaction
s
[Laughter]
Ring the Alarm DJ remix the title card
would you say she was typical of the
patients you see here this is an
emergency psychiatric unit
typical is not really a thing here right
but she was a head case yeah I'm sorry a
head case
you know nothing
crazy you know
she was
smiling she sounds [ __ ] crazy to me
I'm glad they sent you down here
I had a smile managed to bleed through
perfectly there
it's a great shot
yes I mean colors and stuff are very
horror movie
I love an upside down establishing shot
I swear to God I can't better not die
oh no does she see it it's been passed
on
yep
who is that
that's her from the hospital it's
thicker same girl looks like her
Rose
whoa hey train what's up
you are coming Saturday right oh sorry
what's Saturday
I'm sorry is that a joke
it was Jackson's seventh birthday party
wow
normal people hours Rose there have to
be plenty of crazies out there who will
actually pay you for your time how are
you friends with these insensitive
Pricks horrible
people well while we're on the subject
of wasted earning potentials we could
always solve a [ __ ] house can we not
right now please I just I don't
understand you it's literally just the
city we grew up in that house ah oh
that's why they're hanging out can you
guys just shut the [ __ ] up
they're gonna kill that cat I know it
heck he has horror movies in their damn
tropes no no no no no no it's just here
to comfort you yeah it's so dead when
the call came in I had no idea it was
gonna be you so I'm sorry that was weird
that's your job I get it
how you've been they have a history
I appreciate it but I don't need you to
check on me sorry
I have to get back to work
yeah you can help others but you can't
help herself
I like how this movie reveals its
relationships look I just want to say
sorry about last night okay I shouldn't
have kept going at you like that I've
been just dealing with some stuff I
wasn't being very good company
mm-hmm if you need an idea he's really
into electric model trains uh-huh it
follows
she's great who is she she's great oh my
God he's smiling
Carl
you got to be suspicious about the smile
maybe call for backup
she's gonna die I'm gonna die everybody
die Carl look at me you're going to die
you're going to die you're going to die
oh hurry up guys whoa
whoa
eight week off Morgan that's really not
necessary he's been working 80 hour
weeks for months I'm concerned that you
haven't been sleeping
we can't help these patients unless we
have our own mental health in check gun
and badge on my desk
at her niece's party
she has to get that model trained
son of a [ __ ]
you're doing great though so far you've
had almost no reason to smile so
no fair oh notice something happened to
the cat
someone broke in and killed the cat
that's what these movies
I'm sitting here waiting for it too the
amount of emphasis I placed on that cat
everyone
hahaha
I'm gonna give the security company your
password
are you sure
no please
anything but the cat
oh my God that's scary that is scary
yeah
Oh weird
she didn't even have the phone the call
is coming from inside the house
whoa Rose Yuri you need to see a doctor
come on you get help no she got white
wine
that's what it's for it's all clear
what about the back door is it possible
it wasn't fully latched last time it was
closed I don't know maybe
hey I wouldn't worry about it these
false alarms happen all the time
that's gonna make you feel safe
yeah it's a horror movie it's full of
false alarms
his name is mustache is there a reason
mustache isn't responding God damn it
sorry my head has just been in this like
foggy creepy Spacey place all day and
sorry
everything is okay no no I'm fine I was
just venting oh
I feel so bad for you trying to keep her
composure together but
she is falling apart she kind of looks
like Hilary Swank a little bit your odds
of finding a cat after they go missing
are not likely
Laura
who's breathing
you can put her in a dial or isolate on
that
clean it up take out some of the
background his spectral denoise it a
little bit yeah yeah take out some of
the Reverb
S
freaking freak me out
anytime they close up on something man
damn I didn't
whoa
Rose for the knockdown
damn it was good yeah I was like is he
gonna say Rose you know so focused on
the audio yeah yeah that was a really
good one great at guiding your attention
away
it wasn't so much the blood it was um
her face
the look that she had took her face off
I just feel like I've gotten stuck on it
I can't you know get it out of my head
have you considered the reason you feel
stuck
could actually be more about your mother
no that's a pretty weird situation
what's happening yeah this is Extreme
this is advanced
it's my impression experience with your
pay
stress not enough sleep have you been
continuing to see patience while you've
been coping with all this
Rose what about the Risperdal
and let's talk again next week before we
consider any medication she's like at
least like an antidepressant or
something for anxiety
anti-anxiety at least I am
okay surprise coming in come in like
you're headed to a funeral
[Applause]
Hopper grasshopper's mom you're gonna
ruin this kid's opening a presents
aren't you
oh no
there's not a train in there
it's the cat I know where mustache went
away
don't pick it up dude
my boy oh oh [ __ ] no
no
[Music]
what the hell is wrong with
oh
[Music]
you'll be coming oh there she is is that
smile
oh whoa whoa this doesn't stop
God
[Music]
it's been a while since I felt this bad
for someone in a horror movie
something is threatening me
experiencing the same thing before she
died and now it's somehow
attached itself to me
you got really safe sound yeah oh you're
talking about [ __ ] Ghosts no no it's
not it's not a ghost
it's something else it's a demon
crazy
but it's genetic isn't it
oh no there we go mental illness
you can inherit it from a parent
I looked it up why would you look that
up this outside world has like no
concerts
everyone just talks is like the most
condescending way about Mental Health
nobody has a friend or family struggling
with anything
Trevor please
I'm not gonna lie
I'm not even sure what to believe I'm
not either it's good I mean the movie
actually has me yeah I don't know
whether or not it's real or not yet
it's gonna be a reverse a24 you're going
to spend the whole time thinking it's
just a metaphor
geez
what are you crazy
yeah take a drink every time somebody's
movies whenever they almost hit a
pedestrian so watch where you're going
crazy
on this residential Road he was
he was paranoid
then he just stopped sleeping all
together
that night the police called and
told me he was dead
they asked me to identify his body no
wow
okay so it's definitely some type of
entity all right yeah
did Gabriela ever
describe the things that he was seeing
I'll show you oh what oh my she drew
them
whenever they do the drawing some
scribbled
he kept saying it was trying to get
inside of him
damn it's Gabriel's brother he died in
an accident
20 years ago
Gabrielle never got over it
how long had this been like phrase on
trauma the things that he was seeing
they're real I've seen them
what are you a nutcase
some kind of morbid fanatic how
dare you no please please what happened
to your husband is happening to me out
of my house oh come on lady
you gotta have believed your husband to
some extent
yeah I mean I feel like you would almost
want to believe if somebody else could
corroborate
such strange Behavior but then to cope
and try to accept and put it past you
probably not want to believe that it
happened to try to deal with some
reality that the person was suffering
delusions
they'll be grudgingly call back with a
name a man named Gabriel Munoz
killed himself
I need to know if he had been involved
in any other recent police reports now
let's have a b story about
love triangle situation
he gave a witness statement he was
staying at a hotel where a woman
committed
Angela Powell
she's a real estate agent what is this
dude
crime scene photos
let me see it like you don't want to see
this this is this is like evidence or
just you know how about it
ooh there was a previous report filed
four days before death
it's like the ring and it follows on
weird coincidence she was also
interviewed about it is that a video
file
foreign
carve his face off isn't he
oh it's like the burning wow
was he smiling
yeah enhance that reflection times a
thousand it's totally smiling
she's smiling Rose who are these people
you should probably say something yeah I
think now is a good window
make yourself one Ally here he's the
only one who's likely to believe you who
will want to believe you yeah
hey oh
intervention
all I'm trying to do here is help you no
all you're trying to do is make
fine as long as everything is easy and
agreeable but God forbid anything become
real or even a tiny bit difficult
this is more than inside a bit difficult
yeah
what was your relationship like before
this
if that's how you
how you why don't we all just take a
breath why don't you just
I'm being threatened by this entity it's
what killed mustache it was at the party
yesterday but you could see it
nobody else can see it except for me oh
no look Holly I know it's so hard to
believe and it was really difficult for
me to believe it at first either but
look look at this look
it's happened to other people and
they're all dead and I Holly I'm gonna
be next those courses are not real
okay you were having some sort of a
breakdown a breakdown
what you are not hearing me
this is exactly what happened to Mom
just like her repeating this cycle
now mom lost her mind when you let it
Define your entire life and
life and people instead of being some
stay-at-home PTA housewife who lives in
her own smug little bubbles
what oh
oh how did they do that
that's the most disturbing thing I've
seen in a minute
oh Jackson's gonna get it next
whatever Jackson you deserve to you
spoiled little [ __ ]
I don't like you Jackson you're the
worst of them all Jackson
these are very nice Company in Jackson
we talk about people's psychological
conditions with such abandon damn that
was really effective yeah why didn't you
tell me about your patient's connection
to the others after you left I kept
digging these cases this same pattern it
goes back further so far I found 20
cases involving 19 victims with the
direct line linking them all to get it
Jesus
oh
is this partner commit right in front of
them and then four days later tally goes
and he murders a woman he's never met
before a week later the key I witnessed
the murder also commits
pattern resumes Joel I gotta talk to him
huh
let's go see Victor creel what you're
saying is that this thing is jumping
around
from person to person and it is causing
them to kill themselves okay but maybe
it's not
what do you mean
possession
it's kind of like the the guy yes the
security yes that's exactly right back
oh my God what
I know man it's okay you've taken on
Freddy you can do this how long was it
was it between each
like four days
none of them survived from
Buffalo don't worry there's gonna be a
fake out moment where we think you're
gonna be fine and then you won't be
I was hoping he'd be willing to answer
some questions don't answer any
questions I confessed what I need to
know is what you experienced in the days
leading up to it
oh he knows he knows
four days ago a man
killed himself right in front of her
and ever since then she has been
seen
something oh no why is it that everybody
else was seen it as dead in your life
why please did the cop leave
not gonna happen Phil make him leave and
I'll tell you what I know
get out of there she'll just tell you
yeah dude you know she'll tell you yeah
it's something about like it's like a
ring situation has to like pass it on in
some way you gotta go kill somebody
herself yeah
I'd do it
Barbara Jackson
[Laughter]
I was in Brazil a few years ago
a man there escaped that chain
by killing his neighbor and passing it
to his neighbor's wife
yeah she has to make sure there's a
witness for it to pass too because this
thing needs trauma to spread
that's what gives it power yeah exactly
make the biggest mess she can I get
killed one
hmm
you had to have known you have it you're
not giving it back to me
[Applause]
wow
oh he doesn't die after all this
what do you say
nothing
is out of his mind Joel
[Laughter]
yeah killed kill a train in front of
your therapist
you have to keep getting help if it
feeds off trauma maybe the key is to get
over some trauma heal your core wound
trauma is a repetitive cycle
this is not helping
yes
just getting inspiration you know
no
no
no
I knew this was coming Pete
I would just kill Trevor
yeah freaking brings to your terrorist
back right
it doesn't even make an attempt to
believe you
know golly how are you feeling today
I'm pretty sure my fiance thinks I'm
crazy sister has just
totally shut me out my former therapist
is making unannounced house calls if
it's not really there is she yes
should you get that
is the therapist calling it looks like
people you know
yep
been trying your mobile all morning
I'm very concerned about how we left
things yesterday
that was a smile Foreman yeah
[Music]
oh alien
I would have confronted it
don't don't conceal that there
what if he slip who are you planning on
killing or maybe she'll kill the guy
who's certain he's gonna die
but there has to be a witness
hey what if there are multiple Witnesses
there has to be Witnesses yeah
Carl
a
[Music]
what are you doing here
Rose you can't be around patience drop
the knife
oh here we go
pass it on
wow she went for it
she went for it
ugh
wow
[Music]
this is a oh this is a pickle is this a
pickle George I don't think you should
be alone right now I need to be alone
all right
listen Rose I don't think you should go
anywhere okay you just relax I'm gonna
make a phone call all right
damn it hey Jesus uh it's our plan to
isolate herself
yeah
either way it ends with you you know I
would do I would go to a sensory
deprivation tank
and he's all of its victims to pass it
on in order to survive but if there's no
one else around then it has no way to
pass as long as I'm alone I've been to
private of what I need that doesn't make
any sense I'm coming to you just tell me
yeah just hold up alone and then read a
bunch a bunch a bunch of self-help books
cure the trauma
409
yes that's a symbolic number that I
definitely now off the top of my head I
don't worry guys I'm there with you
cleaning products lost foreign
Lord Smiles upon you
good you chose the right cabin
creepiest most run down
rust again
hey Rose I'm calling you for the first
time
today is the first time I'm calling you
me Joel it travels over the phone
your childhood home
that would make the sense
go back to the source
it's crazy last time I had the window
shot going in dissolving into it now her
coming in
parallel framework
describing the journey artistic [ __ ]
pretentious [ __ ]
um
call for health
she didn't do it did she
oh [ __ ]
she let her wow
spooky Lantern perfect
kerosene
ready
mommy's back
this is what happens when you have
trauma
sorry
I haven't been a good mom
yeah
there was something
terrible inside of me
I hate myself
stop
you need therapy Are you ashamed of me
I feel like this entity is helping
around I know
this is what every victim should have
done wish that I would die
I was 10 years old and you were a
monster
that makes a lot of sense
and I know that's not
fair you you needed help
but I couldn't in our stand all that at
10.
this is not real
Rose
your mind
makes it
yeah buddy
oh
wow
[Music]
oh my God this is elaborate yeah it's
becoming a crooked man
foreign
[Music]
hope to gain
oh damn it
oh you can't escape wow what is this
thing oh God
you can't escape it either
whoa what is happening right now no
peace
cleanse with fire
that is a nightmare
did a really tall person come in there
to help
yes
the entities holding auditions
burn it all down
I don't buy it no you always got like a
good fake out how they got away with it
yeah yeah so it's like oh my God yeah
they overcame it oh Jessie things are
great now that's all behind me it's all
in the past his real name is a Train by
just yesterday
Yeah
by mistake
for most of my life
I've been afraid
of letting people get too close I put
walls up
I met you
and
I could feel those walls coming down
and it scared the show
I was
selfish and that was not
fair to you
and I am so
oh yeah bring a lot more nuances than I
expected even asking but do you think
that
that I could stay here to sleep could
you
stay with me while like
he's gonna creepy smile please don't
creepy
of course I'll stay with him
no no what's happening no we'll stay
with you forever
no
goddamn fake outs
get out of there
[Music]
nicely done oh wow
1408 situation over here
what don't trust nope
[Music]
hold on I'm coming no
feed the mama dukes that design is
creepy
wow what in the hell there's her smile
what in the world what Silent Hill [ __ ]
is this
oh
I was just saying herself on fire
gross
no
no
[Music]
shoot the box of matches
[Music]
I can really see it in his eyes great
reflection gag yeah
and now you've got it yep
sequel time
interesting
Nito yeah
christabel Tavia De Vere
oh
Amalgamated Dynamics to the effects
this is a good effects house they've
done
many a thing
what was the director's name
Parker something
Parker Finn or something like that
cow pen
Parker Finn
if there's a post credit scene
I guess I doubt it but also it's the
here and now so probably
it's probably just a quick flash of
someone smiling
I'll Google it
I heard they did a bunch of crazy viral
marketing for this movie where they
would like
buy seats at sports games and just have
actors sit and do the smile
idiots I don't care about all the time
it took for you people to put this
together yeah if I really cared you
could put all this at the front of the
movie you've been paid dude our job is
Judge your hour and 45 minute film
and I attribute that is the only amount
of time spent
making and crafting this experience
fight between this and don't worry
darling we've had two movies with like
really good
paranoid
breath-based scores
yeah there's a lot of prevailing tropes
nowadays
what's the actress's name Kiki Palmer
that's right
and Daniel kaluya was the name
yeah yeah yeah we got a whole new slate
of stars so see bacon
must be
she's great she's two years younger than
us damn go to hell go to hell
yeah who do you think you are
talented at this age screw you yeah get
off your high horse
but who played Greg
yeah
yeah find him Nick are no isn't freaky
that's right he's in freaky
he was funny
dude
cow Peng getting his paycheck
he he did uh you know he did show up
he did uh read the assignment
good old New Jersey
so we saw what the thing was entity did
to her was what happened to the girl at
the beginning of the movie
um
crawled up in her mouth
it's
reverse consumed her
Yeah man they could really sequel this
out and just ruin it yeah they would
never ever have to stop they could
literally ruin this movie and make it a
bunch of weird dumb gags you know how
everything I want the dumb gag to smile
Smiles smiling
still smilers the smile the smile and
then and then the ringer sequel called
frown I've been down man let's make it
happen I don't care
more smile gags yeah more unpacking of
of [ __ ] just yeah just pick a different
trauma each time
um yeah I like the movie I liked it a
lot I thought it was pretty great yeah
you know a bit
a trophy in in the the outline of how it
all goes out yeah
um but it really to me it's about the
the details of it all you know like it's
not like it was 100 predictable or
something like that and it wasn't
you know like I especially on the
freaking jump scare moments like they're
really good at that and yes it did have
me for a while but the second you go
into the territory of investigating a
former person who also had this and
visiting that person I'm like okay it's
real all right yeah they just kept it
about like the patient and her then I
would have been like the whole movie
going crazy
but once they start I'm back in the
second they do that thing of like
someone else before her yeah there's a
cycle yeah other people there's one
Survivor we gotta go talk yeah I think
that's why like something like babadook
which you know obviously the horror
movies I mean I'd be a hypocrite because
I I am the main thing that I'm a big
left to right that's my main passion and
yeah whenever I write for something
horror that tends to be some element of
trauma it is about facing and it's a
very prevalent thing to do nowadays too
and I think from studying the genre so
much you start to see like all the
connective tissues but there are some
good fake out moments and some gorilla
and I love the I love this specificity
of it and especially um what's her name
Kevin Bacon
uh yeah I mean I'm sure she's six
degrees or less from Kevin yeah I think
she's just so excellent of
like she she is very real uh for a
character who has to
constantly find a trying to keep herself
composed and have a sense of control and
understands what perception looks like
um from the outside looking in I think
it was it was wonderful in the way her
her performance feels very real in that
regard especially because
you know like there are a lot of cliches
about
therapists themselves and psychiatrists
who like the cliche like they have a
hard time being psyched themselves yeah
I mean therapies themselves because they
know too much you know more often than
not a lot of people I mean who get
apprehensive about going to therapy are
the ones who are like my degrees in
Psychology my degrees Yeah so I should
already do it myself
so when you're like this far down the
rabbit hole and and also with like the
more I love the depiction of the the
more she's pushed to basically having it
confront her trauma the more resistant
she actually becomes over time like when
she does visit oh my god
um when she does visit the who is the
character in the in the jail the prison
oh Michael K Williams yeah
uh yeah I don't remember the first
character's name was he even I don't
know
uh I feel like let's find out we're on
the smallest IMDb page yeah he was a
surprise appearance
I feel like they didn't want to maybe X
exploit it at all
I guess that would make sense
but he's not created on on IMDb
funny enough I mean by now you could put
his name in there
that is him right yeah yeah they reserve
it for like a cameo yeah yeah I mean
that is that is a good call
um that is true yeah
why did they not um reveal it's not like
I would have been watching this movie
going it's going to be Michael K
Williams coming up
um those were wrong is it a different
actor maybe we just thought it was him
that's embarrassing I'm so confused
right now
it's it's it is odd that he wouldn't be
credited yeah
and IMDb is usually the place where
they'll like catch it you know or or
they'll yeah they'll mark it if it's
uncredited it's so strange
um
Michael K Williams smile movie
uh I guess not
who knows I know I've seen that actor
before I thought it was Michael K
Williams the whole time yeah I did too
I mean the character doesn't even look
like he's credited on IMDb No that's got
to be him
we can't get hung up on this right now
we got a whole movie to talk about John
that's true
um so yeah when the
when uh like the more resistance should
be like when she does leave his at the
place uh the prison and she's like he's
just a crazy guy you know and and she
sort of sounding like the people who
surround her basically because there's a
bit of that joker equality uh with some
of the way that people talk about mental
health in in this constantly he's like
man how are you guys like
that uneducated yeah you guys have like
no concept everybody is so Brazen and
yeah is so kind of uh callous about
mental illness in this movie yeah
there's like a bit of uh because the
movie clearly has an understanding of
what it is that's that's the ironic part
to me it's like the movie clearly has an
understanding and a and a very Vivid
depiction of it with one with their main
character and even to an extent the
relationship with her with her sister
it's it's really like the way especially
her fiance I'm just like oh yeah what
like he's the one who to be like
it's mental illness isn't it it could be
passed down generally like this this is
weird yeah
um that that part was the part that kind
of reminded me of like the way the movie
Joker would sometimes talk about mental
health sure or it's like you have to
explain it for you it didn't feel like
lived in to me but the depiction of what
really counts of the main girl I thought
was really uh Sophie bacon I thought was
was uh wonderfully fleshed out and
and uh and weirdly enough you know even
though there's a big fake out moment I
thought it was cool that they did the
whole grief thing where she does get to
acceptance and a realization about
herself within her own mind
um that they it felt like the movie
really let her get to that point even
though they also the movie got to have
its cake and eat it too where yeah she
does end up taking her own life and then
smile monsters gets inside her and stuff
so they got to do both and I thought the
way they landed the button of acceptance
was felt and I liked how it came through
what was different for me especially in
a lot of these horror movies was that it
came through with the relationship with
Joel because I thought it was just like
yeah you know I kind of expected a bit
of more of a cliche background with them
like he's a cop she's a doctor you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then to
find out that it was through her
relationship with him when she realized
how
scary it was for her to be vulnerable
and let people into who she really is
that she bailed on this
um and I thought that just gave that
relationship so much more depth and went
against a cliche of who the cop of
ex-boyfriend character was very well so
yeah while there's some parts in the way
that the beats that they go to feel a
little cliche and derivative sure uh I
think for the most part the
the details are very very much involved
and exciting and I think there's some
some of the best jump scares too like
these are well done jump scares these
aren't
these aren't you know hacky hokey like
sometimes you can see something coming
more often than I was like what the [ __ ]
yeah well it's because the movie I think
the strength of the movie in general
it's interesting to look at because yeah
like in a lot of ways if you just look
at the nuts and bolts it's quite
straightforward and it's quite well
trodden territory for you know a
haunting Thriller of some kind and so
yeah I mean there are all those you know
sort of tonal things you can check and I
think what's what's great is yeah you
have your sort of like oh it's kind of
like a babadook or it's kind of like a
haunting story or it's kind of like yeah
just a psychological descent but uh yeah
what bolsters everything is the fact I
think that yeah they took the time to
really Hammer the script out and to
really at least yeah give the characters
the main core characters at very least
Rose you know a good Rich history as a
character to work off of it's like a
train is like you know I I think it's
funny it's like he's kind of relegated
to the part of like you know girlfriend
uh that would be in in the flip scenario
of a lot of these movies where it's like
you know there's not really much to that
character whatsoever
um so it's not like it's the whole thing
is like entirely fleshed but the
important things are given a lot more
personality and nuance and I think
setting it in
I think it's um clever to make it so
that she's a therapist because yeah it's
it's we watch these hauntings and these
things happen to regular people so often
so putting it in the hands of somebody
whose job it is to know the mind and to
and who would at least be a few steps
ahead of you know the reality logic in a
situation like this I think like those
things help to make it rise above what
it is and then I also think on the on
the opposite end you have this this
quality with
the gore gags especially that feels like
it's out of another kind of horror movie
like there are some really icky really
disturbing like Gore and creature gags
that I don't know if I've seen applied
to a movie like this in the same way I'm
sure there are examples but it did feel
like that was the most sort of um
outside of this particular genre's
element that they Incorporated because
it's like the jump scares and stuff I
think they work so well just because
they do a really great job of of pulling
you into the performance and pulling you
into the emotion of the situation and so
yeah then they can have fun poking at
you because so much of the other stuff
it's just yeah it's like you're watching
a movie by people who clearly know how
to do drama and to take that drama
seriously and I feel like there are a
lot of movies like this where it's
trying to you know do those scenes but
get to the jumps whereas this is like no
it's like we want you to live in the
anguish and the psychology of this
character and then we're gonna
disconcert you with the jump you know so
it's it's like a a movie you've seen a
thousand times before but it's I think
well conceived for what the core themes
and elements are and it's just really
skillfully done and it's interesting to
watch this kind of on the on the heels
of Barbarian because in ways I I feel
like there are similarities in that
sense of like you have spoilers but you
know you have this thriller you have
this dissent into madness but you also
have a creature element
um but that movie by comparison is much
more sort of it feels much more of like
a wild ride because of how it's
structured out whereas this is like
very linear and very straightforward and
it's funny when it ends because in a lot
of ways yeah it is
kind of what you expected this is not
how you expected it I think yeah yeah
I mean
I think for the most part yeah because
like the thing is the the horror itself
is very effective It's very effective
horror yeah that stuff is executed well
like when you're talking about with the
gore gags especially is
you know the there's like a couple ways
you do jump scares of course and
sometimes you just cut to something
scary like when she's at the laptop
listening to the sound so that's like
you're there she's had the camera's
having you focus on that and you you
expect a certain thing and you get
something completely different
or the I think to me the one of the most
brilliant ones the scary moments is the
one where the sister comes walking to
the door and you know as the audience
like that's probably not really the
sister yeah but the last visual you
expect is what you got it and so like a
truly unexpected horrifying visual
captured in that perspective through the
car window where you can't see the head
because you're like you're gonna just
bend down smiling or some [ __ ] you know
because I think that I think they build
pretty well with the gags you know I I
really do like the way they they handled
a lot of it and I they really got me
invested in the characters because yeah
there's a lot of this that feels very
much like babadook hereditary it's 1408
it follows ring there's a lot of these
these movies where it's like I remember
I think very early on why the reaction I
was I even said like don't I I said like
way before like yeah there's gonna be
some fake out thing that everything's
fine but yeah but that's not gonna be
the thing it's like you could tell it's
gonna do something like that but even
that fake out I bought into because like
1408 does that
um in a way that was not believable to
me I remember watching 1408 supposed to
1408 were you think he's out of the
hotel uh the hotel room there's a whole
thing where he like goes back reunites
with the wife and all this and it's like
a year passes or something like this
yesterday and the whole time I'm like
it's he's still in the hotel he still
knows I can tell it's all in his head
um and then sure enough it's all in his
head he's like yeah I don't buy it and
then here I bought that she at least
went back to the apartment I did I
didn't I was like okay yeah true early
they'd still followed her but I did not
think it was still at the cabin like the
movie really sold me on that you know
and I think that's really clever so as
someone who consumes a lot of horror I'm
always impressed I'm like oh [ __ ] you're
like literally got me and it is it is
scary it's it's spooky stuff and and
there's some really well written I think
the drama is really well written with
with
um I think everything about Rose is
written really well yeah you know even
even with the Joel character written
really well and and um and and I think
when they they find these moments to
have Nuance in unexpected ways like with
the sister you know where it's like you
just seems like you got the loud
annoying [ __ ] sister and then suddenly
they have this this argument out front
and again it plays so much into that
whole thing of
because because the movie's doing both
where it's a recreation of trauma
because she's not over it but it's also
doing the monster movie simultaneously
where uh and I thought it was one of the
rare cases where it was able to do both
I have both where sometimes I feel like
I might not with any of the movies I
just listened but sometimes I might like
be like ah you should just picked one
lane and stuck with it
yeah like barbarians very much
they just it's a monster it's like it's
like freaking crazy movie yeah and it's
not like this is in the Reds you know
like they stick with they stick with
what they're doing
um and like babadook takes a very
specific Direction too in the end uh
without I'll gladly get 1408 away but
I'm okay but babadook takes a very
specific type of ending you know and uh
hereditary kind of has you guessing
until the last frame yep uh and then
here it did both where it is about
overcoming trauma trauma Recreation but
then you also get clued in like halfway
through the movie they make it very
evident that no it's also an evil entity
following you around movie yeah just in
their head uh and and I thought like it
actually didn't undercut the other one
of its in their head it just would have
been more fun if I was like
it's the fascinating case because I'm
trying to think of another movie that
that has left me with this feeling
because yeah I think part of why it's
taken off so huge and why it does stand
out is because yeah it it chooses to
blend those because yeah especially
within I feel like you know if you just
had it be jump scares and there wasn't
really any sort of too crazy of a
monster element or something like that
it would just feel like a pretty
straightforward psychological hunting
story and so yeah it's like even though
the even the combination of the elements
doesn't make it feel entirely unique it
does feel like a unique execution and
it's just like well made enough and and
it has a lot of stylistic flourishes
without going too you know in your face
with it to indulge and I really liked
you know the when they chose to do their
crazy upside down or spinning angles I
thought they were all really
deliberately Chosen and yeah even for
the characters who don't really get much
flesh on the bone yeah it's like the
actors still showed up and and still
understood the assignment and it still
has this the requisite sort of
deteriorating festering Aura of just
this just gets more and more Grim as
time goes by and I think it's it's
interesting to see something like this
where I'm like there are so many
identifiable elements that I've seen a
bunch of times but this felt fresh from
just to Pure experiential kind of
perspective they don't ruin it for me uh
it doesn't undercut it for me and I was
really gripped by the immediate moment
and like I didn't see a big weird
creature coming up at the end I'm like
that's [ __ ] insane yeah and I really
like the design of that that was that
was really unsettling and jarring I I
really like that Design
This is like this is like it follows if
they had the budget to do everything
they wanted that yeah that was the the
thought that that struck me I was like
this feels like the kind of movie that
would get made for very cheap except
they didn't have to make it for very
cheap so they could do all the things
they probably wanted to do all along now
it is like those a24 and appear enough
films with a budget you know and and I
think there's like I heard people say
this is a slow burn and I'm like no it's
not like like it takes its time I want
to call this a sloper that it no like a
hereditary is this
that [ __ ] is like this is freaking
impatient wondering which is gonna kick
off this and I would argue that it's not
being a true Slow Burn is part of why
it's working so well for people because
you have so many of those I thought it
was a Bumpass movie yeah there's a lot
of trailers and I was like I just
assumed this whole time it was one it is
like the blend of those two it's like
it's it's the blend of the a24 paranoia
sensibility but with all the exploitable
pulp that you want from the Blum House
movie that often people feel uh deprived
of in an a20 horror movie well I I think
the part of it that made it so
refreshing the part that I think they
handle very different is normally in
these descent performances with female
healthy they are just going crazier sure
and and I think with the way they
depicted Rose is yeah she is going
crazier uh however it it's a struggle
for composure insanity and not just
succumbing to the the insanity you know
yeah and and I think the way they
handled that there was something that
just felt very real
uh of of this constant awareness of how
other people will perceive her and I
thought that felt very human whereas
usually characters and movies not saying
it doesn't feel human it's just that
usually characters in movies they
completely lose sight of how other
people are gonna perceive that yeah and
she never once loses sight of that and
uh like her her struggle of what to do
and how to proceed about it I thought
was handled really well because because
of the fact it deals with the Mind
language he does go to the hospital when
she first does stab the patient at the
first time she stabbed I thought that
was real then a couple stabbings later
it was like okay is that real but I
first bought into it that it was real
like I didn't question at all that she
wasn't really there and the movie does
do a great job at uh because like the
way she interacts with people of of
there's always this constant Nuance of
like I think our performance is
brilliant because there's this constant
Nuance of
I gotta be polite I gotta be nice I
don't know if you're real though you
know yeah there's always this paranoia
and I'm and I'm their wither of anytime
she's interacting with someone like are
they real yeah and the movie did a good
job on convincing me of that like I
never know when she's talking to someone
who's real yeah yeah yeah totally it
doesn't do too much telegraphing that
way and that enhances the surprises and
that enhances your ability to just tap
into her perspective and it uses the
perspective really well yeah and I mean
they spend I appreciate that they do so
much with performance and they do let
the camera linger and that contributes
to whatever jump scares around the
corner but also it it it serves the both
purposes in a way that like any good
scare gag or action sequence or whatever
should where yeah there's character in
here but also it's guiding your
attention away from what we're about to
poke you with or whatever and yeah and
and her journey feels it's funny this
movie feels like a popcorn like Pulp
movie but the core drama her core
performance the writing of her character
feels like something out of yeah like a
legitimate a more legitimate trauma
yeah that was done really well I was
really impressed with it there's some
great music
um I love the art design I love that it
feels very much like those a24 movies uh
like that yeah it's like solid there's
just something about the lighting that's
like a mixture of like a flat Mike
Flanagan type of thing and well they do
the hospital rooms and stuff yeah they
know really well how to use both
darkness and shadows and and limited
light without cheating but also to use
the light of uh uh common or familiar
places in a way that makes you uneasy I
don't know I think the reason why the
things that are definitely reminders of
other movies it I I just kind of get the
impression
that this writer director
genuinely loves those things and
probably loves those kinds of movies and
stuff and it was probably referencing it
in the process of making it you know
yeah so it doesn't feel like I'm just
going to copy this or this is what works
it nor is it exactly like a moment I'm
paying tribute to it it's just what he
was referenced to making these things
you know for whatever reason I just feel
like the pitch was what if that PG-13
blumhouse movie you thought you were
about to see was also an R-rated a24
yeah this feels like because because
yeah and even I I do think that that one
drool shot is an alien direct reference
and especially because the effects
people have done work on at least some
of the alien movies a lot of times when
people are directing all they really
have to do to kind of convey to their
like their DP and everyone is like it's
coming over for like this this shot here
yeah like when you put these moves
together you put together lookbooks and
then look books you're you're pulling
images from other [ __ ] so they can be
like I'm kind of looking for someone
wants to look like this movie yeah yeah
so I feel like you know it's that's what
it was it wasn't like to steal or
something yeah and then sometimes you
can get a Vibe when you're like you're
just copying other [ __ ] you know no no
or you're not
I don't want to slight like this too
harsh but I feel like that's kind of the
vibe of don't worry darling to me as
much as I actually enjoyed that movie
there are parts of don't worry darling
that I'm like I don't feel like you're
that aware of how derivative this feels
then you know yeah this isn't as
revelatory as you might think yeah I've
seen this before that wasn't the vibe I
got with this film because even like
you're all visiting the guy in prison
who happened to survive and he's kind of
crazy like there's a lot of tropes that
are very familiar
um he's from stranger things like the
second hats for that Guys these Hoppers
yeah he's one of the two guys
my bad yeah good thing we didn't say
Michael K Williams in the reduction and
we waited till the review part I know
now I feel bad uh that's right I play
siblings they could play siblings they
look similar they do in a non-race
system and it's been very hit it's been
a long time I thought that was Tom
Felton the first like 30 seconds that's
why I joke saying it was him I thought
that was funny it's like I I recognize
okay I like that Kyle gallner seems down
for horror movies generally because
that's where I know him from but when
you said that I was like oh yeah it does
look like especially now how Tom Felton
live yeah I thought it was like yeah
um oh yeah he's in Scream he's in Scream
he's from the remake of uh Freddy he's
in a few other horror joints well guys
what did you think about this movie uh I
quite enjoyed it a lot that was that was
fun yeah it's a good year for horror
good year for horror mate all righty
well leave your thoughts down below
subscribe leave a like click that Bell
last but not least let's answer the pain
Chase gardener
Chase
Chase
you've been a patron
for 55 months that's a long time to be a
patron here and I want to thank you for
your service to the reject Nation now
you're going to get bad health insurance
um no deductible you this will not help
you get a job we will not take care of
your mental health but your service to
this nation has been very much
recognized I want you to know that we we
really do respect it will we help you
find employment in other places no no
but you cannot take this to the bank you
cannot but I will say that we we really
appreciate your service to the reject
Nation
in gratitude bucks you are a rich rich
man yeah yeah you're a good guy from uh
where's this
oh goodness Iowa yeah you and I around
Iowa my God man Iowa
oh my god dude
Spirit should we say I don't think so
you said a little too much already there
your spirit is so lovely
you are the spirit of Iowa that's that's
amazing Chase it's all sincerity you've
been supporting us for so long I didn't
even realize it has been that long
um so thank you for being with us for as
long as you have been and it's it's an
honor to have you here and to have
someone who supports us like that
loyally for it does not go over look so
thank you buddy for for everything
um you remain in our hearts and uh very
thankful for you right now so thank you
bud
[Music]